[Music]
[Music]
versus I have a bag that I found that I
think belongs to Greta head tag Oh bless
your heart
where did you find it on the subway Oh
would you like a cup of coffee you've
been so kind I don't get many visitors
here I've been so lonely since my
daughter left well I could help you
my mom actually used to say I'm like
chewing there yes I'd tend to stick
around
[Music]
did you find them
I guess she's been planning bags around
the city sobbing someone brings them
back to her and she said oh my god is
her just not a bring I saw the bags
better I never want to see you again
she's really freaking me out
this is not a problem public area your
rights are protected why are you doing
this how exciting hi I'm Francis I'll be
your waitress for the evening no I can't
do this are you child who knew that I'd
you need a mother to hold you don't you
dare talk to me about my mother everyone
needs a friend
between more than friends
we're connected
[Music]
there's something you need to know about
beretta are you insane
just try to get little Greta
hi I'm Tyler Perry buddy and I we've
been through a lot through many ups and
many downs through new jobs new unions
from haunted houses to the big house
we've seen our share of things some
stories show us how to get through the
hard times with grace and dignity
you're saying one of their movies on
March first cuz your daddy comes a
goodbye Tyler Perry's um idea family
funeral I'll give you some rated pg-13
March first if you couldn't dance what
would you do mm suicide
[Music]
the opposite corner dog food - see - PAH
[Music]
[Applause]
nodosa to pool or to yourself
execute the deep layer butchers voice
yeah yeah
oh you're so good my things I'm so happy
I'm gonna be happier
[Music]
just yesterday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huge barrage fault
[Music]
[Music]
you
but how long do you want the car two
weeks would you like the full insurance
mr. one yeah
do you speak English yes yes
I'm a friend of Samara she's marrying
tomorrow
you have another one f2
everyone rollin sleeping in there Samara
[Music]
[Music]
what do you want
what do you want I don't want to be
married
no he sent me here
what was your plan that we would
disappear we're going without seeing him
do you trust him into a circle of people
everyone living their own life in
it's a perfect place to get lost
she is a fake police are looking for her
okay how long do you think it'll be
before they find you
I trust you so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a tree a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
I keep having these memories something
in my past is the key to all of this
you're not a fly this thing you see
that's a yes or no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
[Music]
I think I had a life here
what aren't you telling me
you come a long way
but you know as strong as you think
[Music]
the slaw is just the beginning
I'm not going to fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm super cute as love thing aren't you
what's your name I read about you in the
paper lies mostly guess I don't really
know how to though I've done enough
you're beautiful kid my father is
beating my mother to death lately with
me a while he'll take us with you
how long given sheriff there two weeks
do not feel special mr. right NEBOSH it
means you're already dead
all of a sudden I'm an enemy number one
there are families in this town hurt by
this man's crimes come again
[Music]
you think she could run for me that one
has to die stack I think that one of
life's partialities what more Stephanie
will be your last
you really think I'm lucky I know it is
my lucky day wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think I do you hurt one hair
on his head I'm taking my nephew with me
every single one of these peoples gonna
tell the tale right you ran they know
it's not true doesn't matter what's true
it matters the story they tell when
you're gone
[Music]
you know hi Peter I haven't heard from
you in a while so I thought I'd give you
a call that's it I love you it's your
mother just goes by in a flash I know
you tell me the same thing every 10
years come here a lot
yes no not a lot I mean sometimes what's
your name
Gloria are you asking me out out out you
want more of the sides not a little bit
more than that
[Music]
she will water I'd be a glass to her
foot I'd be a sock
[Music]
kick it out of my head
happen in a video I thought it was never
gonna happen again happy birthday
sweetheart
that's my ex-husband then what's in any
easy situation really I searched for
your eyes
I didn't exist what is this good luck I
love get away from the car one two three
that woman is awesome treat her right
respect her
it cost me every five minutes don't pick
it up
[Music]
thank you yeah oh my god honey this guy
could die tomorrow we could all die
tomorrow
[Music]
when the world blows up I hope I go down
dancing
[Music]
human touch
we need that touch from the one we love
almost as much as we need air to breathe
I never understood that until I couldn't
have it it never fades away this is my
life with cystic fibrosis out of my face
what would I do without you you dad
people with CF aren't supposed to get
within six feet because we could end up
catching each other's bacteria you
followed me what the intent of
introducing myself and well lumen you're
the kind of guy that ignores the rules
cuz it makes you feel in control am i
right you're not wrong you think that's
cute do you think it's cute do you know
how lucky you are to be here nothing is
going to save our lives we're breathing
borrowed air these meds are not optional
yeah that's probably why they keep
shoving them down my throat okay we're
gonna do our treatments together so that
way I know you're actually doing them
check on funny don't tell me the one
time you're interested in some guy he's
also got CF I just helped him set up his
med cart I know you still of organizing
a med card is like foreplay six feet
apart at all times both know the rules
you catch this infection and you can
kiss new lungs goodbye
[Music]
I don't want to hurt you this whole time
I've been living for my treatments
instead of doing my treatment so that I
could live and I want to live after all
the CF is stolen from me
I don't mind stealing something back
three hundred four millimeters twelve
inches one foot
[Music]
five feet apart are you in
[Music]
good morning Bailey operation wonder
Park is it go they said it couldn't be
done said it couldn't be done
they who's they it's just an expression
don't bust me on a technicality
[Applause]
I never want you to stop using your
imagination but without wrecking the
neighborhood the ever feel like wonder
Park is real of course it could be you
can create anything you imagine from
paramount animation and Nickelodeon
movies why is this here
one at the park you always imagine I'm
in wonder Park
came to life the chimpanzees are tearing
apart the park we need to fight back
Oh No
seems I have backed into the middle of
something backing out beep beep on March
15th it's time to bring Wonder Park back
to life
who's with me oh I still believe in you
if you can imagine it you can ride it
the sky player the fantastic fish
carousel
[Applause]
0g lat
I'm Morla two feet on the ground kinda
guy the Luger coaster you guys did block
the wheels right oh that's what this is
for
[Music]
this is beginning to feel like a
terrible turn of events for us all
wunderbar everyone look away I'm going
to throw up you do this March 15th
[Music]
Rachel no no look at you
[Music]
mr. funding bodies it's chaos out there
this house is being requisitioned by the
British government this is your house
and Lewis telling Logan please come
inside that's my worth
[Music]
my daughter and I will stay out of your
way until we move to the camp what if we
let them stay warm you mean live with
him it may not be an outward show of
hatred but is there below the surface
during the war did you ever hope for a
German victory did the bombing affect
the health of you and your family it
affected the health of my wife she died
in the firestorm I'm so sorry you didn't
tell me what I was walking into this
isn't how it was supposed to be honor
this is how it is supposed to be please
don't go I got a job to do
[Music]
you're going to spy on a girl the least
you could do is pay a compliment
yes of course
[Music]
something's changed be careful that's
why they don't like us
before that I could be happy
come with me this is what you wanted
new beginnings baby brother you got a
big aside
[Music]
hello Gabriel I want a lawyer
you and I both all those days are gone
you have a choice to make work for me or
why not like your father we don't have
much time they're protecting us from
anarchy tell our friends down below they
got our full operational support palm a
neat piece it's a lie they gonna take
everything what do you want me to do
long as we fight back we got a chance
facing a full-blown insurgency known as
Phoenix
then that works communicativeness don't
planning something big
major the team goes tonight you ready no
one gets taken alive hello Gabriel you
have a job to do I've got to play I have
faith in you
light a match
ignite a wall I can take the risk get
back to the way that things used to be
it's like I said those days are gone
you've been in isolation what do you
think about that
I'm not go with people dad
oh yeah I just need you to sign this how
long have you been in prison
twelve years and how long from the
thought of the crime to the actual crime
[Music]
split-second
that's a dangerous animal
if you can stay in there for more than
five seconds you're in the program
nice food the whole purpose system there
how to break these wild horses and
ultimately our rehabilitation you ready
I step into an AB
you might be a cowboy don't tell me it
covered up not that bad first time our
goal is to experience empathy that's it
easy and to be open to our faults if you
want to control your horse first you got
to control yourself I've worked with
horses a long time
some you can break some you can't
there you go
I was a kid and you left me alone was an
accident even riding horses can change
anything I'm not who I used to be
[Music]
there's the cost here I think twice
before you continue put it on my credit
card
[Music]
this ends tonight shocking aw baby
[Applause]
do you have any idea what you're doing
yeah pretty sure I do that's a classic
[Music]
it's not about drugs it's a dope song
don't do drugs can't believe how baby
baby you hear Gabe got a boat he's
kidding right he's not kidding hey I
think it's vodka o'clock oh yeah where's
Jason
[Music]
why were you I didn't know if you were
lost
stick with me I'll keep you safe
[Music]
there's a family our driveway it's
probably the neighbors and John Scavo
family how can I help you sir Patricia
if you want to get crazy we can get
crazy
[Applause]
they look exactly like us they think
like us they know where we are
to move and keep moving
they won't stop until they kill us and
we kill them
[Music]
welcome to the Tosh home to statesman
and celebrities for over a century
Wow remember always here at the Taj
extinct guest is gone let's move
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
chaos has erupted in Mumbai with
multiple bombings and armed gunmen
rampaging through the city
look I don't think you understand
there's been an attack and we're not
safe
switch off the lights
terrorists have laid siege to the
landmark Taj
when as many as a thousand guests and
over 500 staff trapped inside if you try
to gather whoever we can any of you have
families at home there is no shame in
living I have been here 35 years this is
my own
is on a hominid about or they are
local police are simply not trained to
deal with attacked of this magnitude
[Music]
and I hope to stay home - see them go
down the back stairs and straight out
the services with the harassed men all
died we take our chances
[Music]
Murdock get through this we must stick
together
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome baby Dumbo all family here no
matter how small
[Music]
[Music]
unless something very rare you have
wondered
[Music]
you have the mystique
[Applause]
you have magic
[Music]
come with me
together we can soar on the elephant's
wings
what's happening were they taking her
take Dumbo back inside but she's his mom
do something she needs us look at me
we're gonna bring your mama home
he doesn't look like magic to me
[Music]
your children need you to believe
you can do a Dumbo shoulder
[Applause]
side of them
fly baby
I accept whatever words they give me
this job with a bit of a politics war
play
one day I will swallow
and when I do I hope you all perish
silently
yeah hey you look like [ __ ] I look like
I always look
you have pissed away your talent on
women and booze and now you're talking
that's of fees the juices up here in my
noggin man
and get all these things going they
start tail music the world's reverb went
back and forth and hit the frequency
I start to dance to it my fingers get
moving
spinning all the taste and the words
come out
girl stops now the foolishness
you're gonna publish your novels and if
you mess this up is Chilton
wish me luck I'm off to write the next
great American novel I may have a
gangbang when I get back I will invite
your mother
thank you for someone dog I'm trying to
uncover my connection with the world
just follow me my friend let's go win
see good pilot mom perfect
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you